So the answer is that we need to
consider a newer coordinate frame and
we would refer to this as
the homogeneous coordinate system.
Basically what we want to do is
actually take the two dimensions
that we were looking at before,
the x, y, and
the x prime and the y prime,
and a two dimensional matrix M.
Let's start seeing if we can actually
represent this as a three vector.
So so far we've looked at x and y.
So we want to be able to take
this two dimensional x y and
generate a new three vector.
We can basically refer to this as x y
and the third vector being 1, and for
just sake of completeness and
what we will do with it
next let's call this a w.
So what we basically doing is
we adding a third coordinate to
every two dimensional point.
So and what we did basically is
now we're coming up with x, y, w.
And the thing we want to remember is
what basically w implies is again,
my two dimensional vector, except
that now we are dividing both x and
y with that third point here, w.
Now of course there are certain subtle
things we need to pay attention to.
Here for example is my simple
two dimensional x and y.
I can basically look at
this point here 2 and 1,
of course just looking at x 1,
y 1, the values would be 2 1.
Now just keeping this convention
in mind, if I had omega,
or w to be 1 this still makes
unreasonable sense 2, 1, 1 applies, but
then of course,
imagine I could work w to 2,
then 4, 2, 2 applies and
if I make w be 3, 6, 3, 3 applies.
So, this point now can be
represented by this three vector
in all three of these values.
One thing to note, w cannot be 0
because if you make this 0 x and
y also would actually go to infinities,
so of course when w is 0 we can
refer to that as an infinite point.
This point, 0, 0, 0 is not allowed
because we cannot have 0 over 0.
That would be an indeterminate point.
But all of a sudden, now we have
a lot of strength in our hands,
when we actually now create
this new coordinate system,
the homogeneous coordinate system,
with x, y, and w.
Let's see what that buys us.